c'est le recueillement qui était à
l'honneur samedi soir à erevan où
plusieurs milliers de personnes se sont
rassemblées à la tombée de la nuit sur
la place de la liberté munis de bougies
de fleurs de drapeaux arméniens et de
celui de l'artsakh ainsi que d'icônes
orthodoxes la foule était très calme
presque silencieuse les manifestants ont
ensuite entamé une marche dans les rues
de la capitale encadrés par un important
cordon de police lors de cette marche
les noms des personnes décédées dans les
combats s'étaient pana cartes ont été
cités ana dans un mégaphone
et puis hormis ce recueillement on a pu
aussi entendre de la tristesse du
désarroi et de la colère chez les
manifestants
j'ai beaucoup de peine pour ces gens des
jeunes gens qui combattaient pour leur
patrie vous comprenez c'est tout
simplement terrible vraiment terrible et
mettez nous avons perdu ce territoire
très anciens du haut-plateau arménien en
angola j'ai tant de gens sont morts pour
rien réglé 10h fois cet événement devait
avoir lieu
nous nous souvenons ici spamina n est
pas maître montage n'est pas stick
devons honorer la mémoire de nos lions
qui ont combattu aller braver contre la
turquie l'azerbaïdjan les terroristes
azerbaijan terre est restée dans les
gazettes environ 110 personnes se sont
battues contre une armée de plusieurs
millions de millionnaires
je ne sais qu'une chose les ans et des
mandats d'arrêt dans ma ville de chouchi
mamadou ni hadjout
sur des villages mais ce ne sont pas
seulement des villages ou du temps nos
jolies habits bien oui c'est notre
histoire pas couru
randy nous la paix rendez nous la paix
rendez nous la paix et notre vie nos
sérieuses et à quelques centaines de
kilomètres de là dans le haut-karabagh
les habitants restés sur place sont
revenus dans leur habitation depuis
l'apaisement des tensions se retrouvent
soulagé puisqu'il ne craignent plus
autant pour leur vie depuis que les
combats ont cessé certains d'entre eux
tiennent à remercier les forces russes
de maintien de la paix nos équipes sur
place ont recueilli leurs témoignages
nous tenons à exprimer notre profonde
gratitude au peuple russe et aux soldats
russes de la mer qui sont arrivés ici et
nous ont aidés à mettre fin à la guerre
merci beaucoup je pense que notre peuple
retrouvera enfin la peine je suis vous
j'habite ici depuis ma naissance je suis
d'origine arménienne
dans cette situation la russie a joué un
grand rôle un rôle très important grâce
aux troupes russes tout s'est arrêté
comme un grand merci à eux pour cela là
je veux espérons le meilleur pour tout
le monde
selon le ministère russe de la défense
environ 250 habitants de stepanakert
sont rentrés chez eux les neuf premiers
bus sont arrivés dans la ville après le
déploiement du contingent de maintien de
la paix